we traveled to the texas border last
week for the third time in the last two
years and i was able to see firsthand
how this crisis has expanded throughout
texas from el paso to mcallen to del rio
now border agents tell me migrants are
expanding into arizona watch
just between september 19th and
september 25th we had over five thousand
rest fifty four hundred arrests in a
very small sector this isn't a big this
isn't a large area
he's referring to yuma arizona joining
me right now the man who is fighting to
stop this surge texas governor greg
abbott governor it's good to see you
this morning thanks very much
before we get to what your
administration is doing to stop all of
this um assess where we are are you
seeing this crisis expand beyond what we
saw a year ago
oh absolutely listen
a year ago of course was still during
the trump administration and the trump
administration had put in place all the
policies that led to the greatest
reduction in cross border crossings uh
but but now we're seeing the highest
number of cross-border crossings and
it's all because of the catastrophic
open border policies by the byte
administration and we're seeing more and
more people come in but i got to tell
you maria there is something
that's happening that's getting even
worse and that is the cartels are
getting even more aggressive and the
cartels on the mexican side of the
border they're beginning to
open fire on the national guard that the
texas has down on the border to secure
the border this is escalating into a
firing war
on each side of the border where texas
and our national guard are having to
defend themselves and defend the
statistic defend the state of texas
so so just to be clear we were in del
rio you say it's getting worse
in other areas of texas then
sure so everybody saw what happened in
del rio with regard to the haitians that
came in there but right now the hottest
point
is in roma texas uh in star county area
uh and and that's the area uh where the
cartels on the mexican side of the
border are shooting uh at the national
guard on the texas side of the border
and so what texas is having to do we're
having to step up and guard multiple
points across the entire border
unbelievable and i know these mexican
cartels are very smart they know how to
flood one area so it opens up another
area so that they could get through
smuggling humans and and drugs across
we've got new unofficial numbers from
one of our border sources it says that
in in the last month we saw 187 000
apprehensions but of course the number
of got aways is much higher 42
649 got aways 91 people died in the u.s
in the desert
what do you want to say about these got
aways we just heard from two ranchers
that said they're watching their
property damage every day they have to
carry their gun everywhere they go
including to throw away the trash
well listen those ranchers were spot on
in their assessment and that is the bite
administration has completely abandoned
those ranchers the bad administration
has completely abandoned all the people
who live on the border they have
abandoned people in the state of texas
and marie these are counties and these
are people who traditionally have voted
democrat that the bad administration is
ignoring and he's putting them in danger
and you heard that rancher talk about
the need to carry a gun remember biden
said there was no need for anybody ever
ever to have a gun of more than six
bullets or six rounds whatever the case
may be these are people who need the
firepower to be able to deal with the
cartels who may be coming across the
border and so this is exactly why people
need their second amendment rights to
protect their own
safety and defend themselves on the
border but this is also exactly why
texas is stepping up to do more than any
state has ever done to help to secure
this region so that we can help ranchers
like that it's why texas has devoted
more than three billion dollars to
secure the borders while we have the
national guard and the texas department
of public safety on the border is why
texas itself is building a border wall
to make sure that we will be able to
better secure our border
well how can you do that i mean you're
doing that just on state land i know
because the biden administration last
week said that it's cancelling all the
remaining border wall construction
contracts in that area so i was there
witnessing walls that were half done and
the other half is wide open i mean it's
quite easy to just get out of you know
come in from the rio grande jump over
and get in a gut away car and and i just
want to point out that we understand
another thing that i learned last week
is that these getaway cars are being
driven by americans so the cartels are
advertising their services on tick tock
and snapchat i'm told so look at this
graphic where we show cartels are
charging the migrants from the northern
triangle eight to ten thousand dollars
but then they're paying american
citizens a thousand dollars to be that
getaway car ninety percent of the cars
stopped with illegals in them are
actually driven by americans what can
you tell us about this
well first of all it's true second is
something that the texas department of
public safety has been working on
and we just made it far easier for the
texas department of public safety to
both arrest and be able to prosecute
these people who are assisting and
smuggling this is an accomplice to a
felony in the state of texas and so i
signed a new law that makes it easier to
crack down on smugglers in the state of
texas and we are going after these
people who are responding to these tick
tock requests who are assisting the
cartels and smuggling people in the
united states that is a crime and we are
looking to put these people behind bars
just extraordinary governor i want to
switch gears and ask you before you go
about these vaccine mandates texas and
florida banning covent vaccine mandates
now the white house is accusing you of
putting politics ahead of health uh
what did you decide why did you decide
to ban it and set the record straight
for us does federal law override state
law on what you can do with regard to
mandating a vaccine look at all of the
people resigning right now
uh well you make a good point about all
the people resigning because that's one
of the problems with regard to the
supply chain because so many people who
are being forced to get a vaccine do not
want to do that and hence they're
leaving their jobs however to answer
your question
clearly
what
president biden is doing is
unconstitutional there is zero authority
in the constitution that gives the
president or
his administration the authority to
mandate anybody taking a vaccine and
that's why we feel very confident
that the state executive order will
supersede the federal executive order
because the federal executive order is
completely unconstitutional
we want to make sure that our fellow
texans who have been forced into this
impossible situation about
providing for their livelihood versus
being forced to take into their body
something they do not want that it will
be the state stepping up and protecting
the individual liberty of our fellow
texans from being forced to take a
vaccine that could cause them harm
that doesn't take in effect uh the
acquired immunity they motherwise have
it doesn't take into effect the severe
reactions now that some people are
having the shots uh and i got to raise
with you maria something else that
people haven't considered and that is
where does this end uh we're talking
about a federal mandate for a shot
as you know there's waning effectiveness
of these shots are are people going to
be required by the federal government to
take a shot every single year for the
rest of their lives
americans need to come to grips with the
unconstitutional overreach by the body
administration
well it's a it's an issue and a point
that is well taken a lot of people are
worried about that and that's why we're
seeing all these resignations uh from
nurses and
and military
that's going to have an impact on the
economy as well because
already businesses can't hire the people
that they need that governor thank you
thanks very much for all of your efforts
and for joining us this morning governor
greg abbott